sto aspettando di registrarlo
letteralmente da mesi sto video Adesso
vi spiego Allora partiamo dal principio
surry piace quando inizio un video e
parlo di surry fece tempo fa un video
sul suo corredo genetico a sponsorizzato
Tra l'altro questa azienda che offre
questo servizio di analisi del corredo
genetico per risalire ai propri antenati
sono stato influenzato da surry quindi
top influencer bravissimo perché ho
comprato io questa cosa qua lui l'han
pagato io l'ho comprata Questa è la
differenza di chi sa fare business e chi
no perché ero troppo curioso di vedere
Effettivamente da dove provengo da dove
vengo da che pianeta perché Favij
sicuramente non può essere terrestre mi
è arrivata a casa questo kit che
contiene una sorta di tampone tipo
quello del covid però non ve lo dovete
infilare nel naso neanche nel culo tipo
nella guancia Bisogna raccogliere un
micro campione di saliva e questo
campione bisogna mandarlo poi negli
Stati Uniti dove viene appunto
analizzato Dopo mesi sono arrivate
finalmente i risultati dell'analisi mi
ha fatto partire il video così è un
video un po' a cazzo chi se ne fotte
Eccoci allora
Allora sono italiano al
39%. Sono Greco Ma in che senso sono
Greco Santorini discendo da Ercole Ho
una fonte di corrispondenza con una
persona famosa
Grazie al cazzo sicuramente un parente
che si chiama FAVIJ Bari Puglia alcuni
dei loro discendenti degli Stati Uniti
Vabbè ci sono dei parenti degli States
non si Boh vabbè ma Greco dove diciamo
Scusami ma com'è In che senso 30 Ma quei
30 ragazzi 33 è tantissimo Ci sono quasi
Greco quanto italiano Cioè sta roba Non
ha senso ma di chi di Zeus Vi prego poi
dall'Europa settentrionale occidentale
pesa un po' ovunque qua Va bene E poi
addirittura un 4% dell'Asia Turchia
Georgia ua di qua vedete che è un mio
parente era a Dubai è partito Si è fatto
tutto sto casino qua è arrivato in
Grecia nel mentre ha chiamato due tre
volte e poi è arrivato in Italia è
successo questo non lo so Comunque qua
Ragazzi c'è la panoramica quella fatta
bene e abbiamo le corrispondenze tra
famiglia prossima quindi parenti vicini
me ne dà uno preciso eh parenti estesi
quindi cugini di cugini e poi parenti
lontani quindi persone che condividono
in qualche modo il mio dna nel mondo e
sono 1.500 70 e qua nelle foto vedo solo
però devo pixellarli Per privacy
Comunque sia acido urico qua ti dice
dove sono finiti eh tutti quanti i miei
parenti quindi non gli antenati Ma
quelli che stanno che vivono attualmente
Dove diavolo sono dislocati io ho 291
corrispondenze le mie DNA negli States
145 in Francia e questa cosa fa male fa
male qui qua proprio fa male Vedi che so
che è sporco fa male qua perché le
pixwords devono analizzare lo sapete
tutti 133 sono crucchi 99 svizzeri 97
Regno Unito e 65 italiano Cioè proprio
italiani Ma che che ci sto a fare io qua
non ho capito Cioè praticamente i miei
parenti sono cinque volte tanto negli
States piuttosto che in Italia Ma di che
diavolo stiamo parlando cioè
praticamente Ho parenti in Italia Svezia
un altro po' va bene Poi nei Paesi Bassi
Danimarca Finlandia Norvegia Australia -
Austria - Ungheria abbia Poi c'è tutto
il casino Spagna 16 un cazzo ce n'è uno
in Giappone Attenzione uno o una
corrispondenza giapponese e coreana Tra
l'altro non so se sia giapponese ancora
uno o l'altro non è che possa essere
tutte e due vittorie Si è accorto vorrei
prima di concludere guardare com'è la
Grecia cioè i miei antenati Sono
effettivamente provenienti da un quarto
di loro dall'Europa in generale un terzo
dalla Grecia Quindi io sono solo per un
terzo italiano a quanto pare così si
capisce che effettivamente ha senso da
qua sono arrivati a Bari non si sa come
Però effettivamente mi antenati
provengono dalla Grecia Speriamo che io
siamo ma una cosa Afrodite mi madre ma
che cazzo ne so ma poi Santorini Ma in
che senso ma Santorini in generale O
vengo la Santorini No in generale Questa
è Sparti Allora se io ascoltassi
qualcosa di greco dovrei in qualche modo
c'è il mio cervello proveniente da
quella zona dovrebbe riconoscere
qualcosa vediamo
Peccato perché secondo me c'era del
potenziale Grazie comunque siamo tutti
figli di nostro Signore Gesù Cristo
quindi c'è uno zero di cento di tutti
noi in ognuno di noi e non ho capito
neanche questo detto però comunque molto
molto interessante sta roba ragazzi
molto interessante va beh video corto
sti cazzi ma volevo fare sta roba perché
ero molto curiosa Adesso passerò la
giornata a guardare queste robe però
concludo qua non voglio ammorbarvi tanto
che me ne frega sono italiano Greco
svedese un po' giapponese e spero che
Siate contenti per me perché io sono
molto contento quindi signori Spero che
il corredo genetico vi sia piaciuto un
po' strana sta a conclusione del video
aspetto che surry mi influenzi con
qualche altra cosa per risplendere i
miei soldi Grazie scusa sei da sempre la
number one persone nella mia vita che mi
fa spendere del denaro non ho ancora
capito come però è così Ciao ragazzi